[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
next week
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on guys
appreciate you coming back through for
the attic show attic review whatever you
guys want to call it these days
uh i guess it's kind of both isn't it
dirt i had to show an attic review
obviously if you guys see the titles
we're going to be going over a few
things man we're going obviously we
gotta make a little spicy too like it's
not one of those things that you know we
got to make it spicy like
some sauce
stuff happen
audio is very low so i'm low okay so
dirt was saying that i was low
let me make sure that it's on the right
thing
yeah it's only the right thing hold up
it sound like when you get closer to the
mic it it yeah
all right the sound when you get closer
does that sound better you sound better
than me yeah
the sound is at five percent
it shouldn't be at five percent hold up
let me get my phone
you guys got to deal with an echo for
about 15 seconds
you good
yeah i don't know
i said you sounding low oh okay so flame
said i'm good but you are low
how am i low
i'm not straight so flame said i'm good
but you are low all right how am i low
let me see what the actual zoom thing is
all right what about now you sound good
now you sound yeah all right let me turn
it down just a little bit because i saw
it go in the red all right how does that
sound guys you guys gonna have to
yeah i don't want to be too loud now i
won't be too loud because then you guys
gonna be complaining that i'm too loud
what about now man what about now
there we go okay okay i assume that
we're good i assume that we're good
yeah we're good now
all right all right so for sorry about
that guy sorry about that but anyway
we're back with another attic show where
i speak the past present future gaming
uh no co-host today unfortunately uh
hustle had some real life situations
that he had to get done uh but we got
dirt greg eddie what's going on dirk
what's up my brother three weeks in a
row man three weeks in a row hey let's
be real here it's there's so much hot
stuff going on with xbox man we got to
get an xbox representative in here yeah
i play whatever side i want to play
every i play whatever side i want to
play uh sometimes on the villains
sometimes on the villain you guys want
sometimes on the villain you guys need
uh so you know we we're gonna go over
obviously the xbox show we got a lot
going on that we're going to go over
some stuff that was said during it now
there are a little bit that was said
that we do have to go over in terms of
there are a little stuff that wasn't
said during the shows but i feel like
it's important so we will be going over
stuff like that as well the attic for
the streets you guys are ridiculous all
right so
let's
let's go ahead and first off you know ha
how was this week have you been gaming
much this week dirk i don't think i
damned one day this week i
i dabbled a little bit in the quarry but
that's about it oh it's been a pretty
busy week uh you know doing this podcast
my own guest starring on podcast it's
been a pretty hectic week bro so no i
haven't had much gaming then got much
gaming in yeah so i played a little bit
of destiny then i played um demio they
got a new update coming and i got my
hands on an early build of it uh they
got like a new character and stuff
so i'm been working on that i'm going to
have some coverage on that on the iop
channel i'm going to be streaming
the
the quarry eventually on iop i'm hoping
to do it tomorrow i i definitely
appreciate people uh you know there's
like 15 people wait i felt bad i
couldn't do it
like it's just like look like i had so
much stuff going on my work ended up
mandating me for almost 17 hours i had
to
and you know by the time i got off it
was like four or five-ish i uh i worked
from
midnight the
to seven to
five p.m the next day
wow and so by the time i got home i was
like well you know maybe i should just
go home and maybe i should just get you
know do this quarry stream because i
probably because i already pushed it one
day because the girl came over she
wasn't supposed to and she's like while
i'm on my way i was like well i can't
sit here for two hours streaming so i
was like that got to be ended so i i
delayed it a day but then work kept me
another day so you know and i was just
you know i was i was going home and i
was thinking about myself
i'mma be dead what's the point of me
doing a show like my energy gonna be low
you're gonna get like
hey guys like we ain't doing that that's
not how this works so yeah you know uh i
was like
they'll wait for me yeah
i ain't i got i got to be 100
i work tonight hopefully i don't get
mandated again tomorrow but if i don't
probably about 5 p.m is one we do it
five probably
yeah many corey's already so far so i
mean you might like it if you like those
type of types again oh i love those type
of games
my favorite uh playstation uh one of my
favorite playstation exclusives well
you'll definitely like this one
and what's funny is
i got a review code but they sent it the
day of like no look i appreciate the
opportunity
but i do feel like
as the publisher if you're gonna give
games out the day of
what are you realistically hoping them
to achieve in that short amount of time
you know what i'm saying right so it is
what it is i appreciate the opportunity
regardless uh you know but i'm gonna
stream it and then what i'm gonna do
after i stream it is i'm going to
review it on the iop channel and then i
got dbr got to work on which you know
there's a new character which is crazy
she's a crazy character for those of the
chat that saw our demio interview uh she
uh it's a character that controls a dog
and like because it's like a tabletop
rpg like you pick up dice and throw it
on pc now it's it's a fun game i really
enjoy it i definitely think you guys
should go out there and look at that uh
but you know
i feel like
this is a good time in gaming now
obviously we're going to talk about
these events you know we're going to
talk about that there's a couple things
that you know we got to go over uh first
thing we're going to talk about probably
do you think we should wait for the star
field in red fall uh we should dissect
that after we talk about the show itself
um probably yeah we should get to the
the overall show first and then kind of
go specific games all right yeah a
pacific you mean starfield and red fall
i ain't talking about most of these
games
um all right so
got a two dollar super chat from yeah
baby farva
your baby father what's up
what's good fellas chat what's good dirt
i'm
mod
that's a that's the thing i don't do on
my uh channel
yo i was
you know what's funny because i usually
always uh listen to your podcast um like
over a speaker or something i don't
watch it i listen to it but the other
day i started listening to it and like
man you have some crazy segments in that
thing yeah we do man we we have some
crazy stuff you know my my playstation
cry baby man baby whatever he is you
know i you know i would play the clip
and i would do a live voice over
all right man so that's what like
look you know like
your baby father got i'm mad from
uh so yeah i had a bunch of different
stuff man you know i just try to be a
little different you know we'll see i
feel like we need more of that more
creative minds uh you know because i
took a little bit of
you know the format we do on ilp which
people people were sitting there
clowning on me saying that i jacked
ilp's format i helped make iop's format
you can't jack something you helped me
first off exactly uh second off
uh
i don't know what to tell you guys uh
i don't know i don't know why it didn't
bother me but i was just like how people
maybe they were just trying to
trying to annoy me which they succeeded
so let's go and talk about the xbox
showcase 2022. first thing i want to
know man is what are your general
thoughts on this what is
first off what was your expectations
going on here and then what was your
thoughts when you actually watched it
and did they meet anything like we ain't
gonna go into games too much right now
we're gonna go into the pacing or
anything but what i want to know is what
was your initial thoughts right before
this show started and what was your
thoughts after it did you know did it
kind of meet expectations any okay uh
well initially my expectations was up
here because you know you say xbox has
all these studios they've shown they've
shown a road map a huge amount of games
in development i'm sure we're going to
see some of those games but i would say
there's one of my panel members he said
um
when they announced when sarah bond
announced they're only going to show the
next 12 months worth the games that's
when stuff went downhill from that
so so that the right process of
elimination so y'all could
already say okay there's no um
that's no perfect dark there's no fable
you know you're okay fine
um then the show itself i thought it
started off fine it's all fine i thought
real follow great you know then
something happened towards the middle
uh they showed a lot of games i you know
i guess
i didn't really care for personally but
i think um
the end it ended well so it it started
off good
the middle was kind of uh down for me
then ended well so uh my expectations of
the show was high it it didn't meet my
expectations but the show wound up being
around a seven for me you know what i'm
saying because because it wasn't the
best show like i mentioned like pre-show
it wasn't as good as last year
but it was better than 2019 and 2020 in
my opinion
you know so it didn't quite meet my
expectations but it wasn't that bad of a
show but they've had better shows than
that though yeah they've had a few
better shows than that
uh well it looks like we got uh bg's
here man you ca
is your audio stuff working yet bg you
started setting that up
uh yeah i hear you
what's up bg appreciate you coming
through man we we needed someone a
little bit more on the other end you
know uh
i
was pretty hard on them and i was told i
wasn't supposed to be that hard uh but
you know it is what it is uh so how did
you
personally feel what the way we're doing
at bg is we're talking about
the your general expectations going into
this event and we're talking about uh
you know how you felt after it and do
you think it succeeded or was the uh
expectations that you had for this event
uh
so i didn't really yeah i i didn't
really have um
my expectations were neutral i'll say
they were neutral
uh
turned out to be
i think
it just wasn't a lot of games that
interested me right
from what i got from you know other
there were some like you know xbox xbox
fans i saw the side of people who
completely loved it and then
um i saw the people who
thought it was okay but the games that
were shown were not you know still not
necessarily what they wanted to see you
know they wanted to see the the ones
that were you know everybody put up on
their list that they're excited about
the avowds the
um you know the outer worlds the perfect
darks all those things you know and they
didn't that was where i was at yeah they
didn't get to see those so for me it was
just honestly it was like maybe two
max three games that were shown that i
was interested in you know that out of
the whole conference so that was it for
me all right so uh dirk go ahead and
finish your statement sorry i think i
interrupted you because bg came in and
uh kind of oh no no no no i was done i
was just agreeing with bg that i was
that second guy
that you know not every game interests
me i was expecting to see some of the
bigger games that have already been
announced like a vowel and you know
perfect dark but like i mentioned when
she said 12 months i said okay they're
not going to have those
that's a few years out
so
but you know it was
it was okay though no it was okay
all right so
here's how i felt all right i did
i actually thought i had reasonable
expectation expecting to see
a vowel i didn't i threw stuff like
perfect art out stuff like what's
another game perfect dart i threw out i
threw fable out said we weren't going to
see ever wild i felt like i had
realistic expectations and it still
wasn't met um you know i understand
to to me and i don't know how you guys
feel i actually prefer the 12 month
thing over uh you know the couple years
thing maybe they have an xo that goes
more into detail on what the future
plans of xbox is but the e3 part of the
show is relative like this is what
you're going to be playing in the next
12 months
i actually like that because i like
knowing that all these games i'm have
access to in the next 12 to 15 months
because let's be real here
even starfield might get pushed back
past that 12 month mark uh so you know i
like that now i'm not gonna say that
this game was a bad show it wasn't a bad
show it just
it was good on paper for the people
would apply to it was bad on me because
i didn't really care about 80 of the
show i'm gonna be real with you um i
actually felt like
one of the saving grace was star filled
now i do think it was looking a little
fishy we'll go into that a little later
uh but i don't think it's looking as bad
as everyone else thinks but you know
we'll go into that momentarily because
if you have a whole topic dedicated to
starfield and red fall but when it comes
to the actual show it's like i said i
think that the game had great pacing
then i know people like try to
like descript what pacing in a in a in a
show means i personally feel like pacing
is how long you spend on a game and you
go to the next game and the quality of
the games that you spend on that's what
i feel like pacing is and i can unders i
think the pacing was there it's just the
games didn't appeal to me so it felt off
to me but if they had better in these
better games in general and they
replaced the the games that i didn't
particularly care for then it would have
been a lot better it's just i personally
felt like it was the games that didn't
appeal to me more than the pacing of the
show
yeah i understand um
you know i watched the show a couple
times you know the second time i watched
it in in 4k
hey and you know the show did get a
little better but there was like that
middle
like there were some games i just didn't
care for
um but there was a games that actually
looked better the second time i watched
it you know um because i'm like that
game high on life that is a game that
looks incredible to me not a lot of
people talking about the game you know
the game that was made by the people
that wrote rick and morty or whatever i
think that game was dope you know what
the that looked fun
yeah it was fun so so there was a few
indie games
that caught my attention the second time
the first time my move was kind of
because i'm going to be honest here guys
after i saw you know well
after i saw a a certain xbox first party
game my move got really bad
impediment
i knew the game was going to be a small
game
but i was expecting
something different than that so i and
so my move was like really negative
um then then it picked up towards the
later of the show
yeah i'm not gonna you know we could
we'll go ahead and go over uh some of
the general things uh one thing i do
want to bring out is uh here's the games
now keep in mind you know i have a
couple games we're going to stop on
but
if any of you want to talk about
individual games when i read over them
uh tell me to stop so we got we got red
fall we have a point dedicated to that
we don't need to go into that because i
feel like that was one of the highlights
so ironically considering i've low-key i
haven't been talking snap about it but
it didn't look appealing to me up until
now
uh hollow knight silk song i actually
like this i know you're you're a fan of
this type of uh genre of bg did you like
the showing that they showed with that
game uh i i like the genre of apollo
hollow knight so i haven't called it
hollow knight um i haven't like played
hollow knight itself yet so uh i need to
download it um
because you know jack with my share
partner i'm pretty sure he bought it so
i need to try it out so i can't really
speak on hollow knight right now it was
on game pass
i don't know i don't i don't indel i
don't indulge in such things
all right and then let me grab this just
to be honest i said then we got
high on life now this game doesn't look
like something i would play normally but
when i was looking at this game i was
like you know what i might actually mess
with this game i might actually try
i don't know why
it's the personality of the game the
chemistry of the game like this is a
game that i would normally skip but when
i'm seeing this game like this actually
might be fun now how did you guys feel
about how in life
i'm curious to hear bg because i know bg
is mainly on me when it comes to stuff
like this when you saw this high in life
i haven't looked at your reactions
because you normally look at your
reaction but i was so disgusted with the
show i didn't want to see any more of
certain parts of the show
yeah it didn't do nothing for me man
right off the rip i'm not the craziest
about first-person shooters right like
there's
some first-person shooters i like
but
it has to be special for for me to like
it
and
i don't think the whole
like comedic you know
goofy
uh first-person shooter that doesn't
take itself seriously
um
thing
really does it for me like the only game
like that that i like is like
borderlands you know borderlands
purposely tries to be funny
but the but the rest of them
i think it's
yeah
it didn't do anything for me i'm like
this is a skip i i don't care about it
i'm not i'm not playing that you know
i've never even watched rick and morty i
guess if you watch rick and morty i've
never watched rick and morty either
maybe you care but i think it just it
looked entertaining it didn't look fun
at the time it just looked entertaining
i don't know how the gameplay is going
to play
i don't know if it's going to be a fast
play slow place like average pace but
you know who i want to hear from dirt i
i i know
you know uh we we've been talking a lot
about this show but when it comes to
high on life it really did feel like the
developers were high when they were
making that game because they gave it
it's got a talking gun like how did you
feel about this though the weapons are
talking trash bro
like the one scene where the knife
with the eyeballs you know like you were
stabbed he was like yeah it's time to
stop stop
listen bro i like to be entertained i
like
mostly all genres of games except for
maybe you know real-time strategy i'm
not a big fan of those but
i mean i just
it looks interesting to me i remember a
game on the original xbox called was it
uh stranger the stranger
it was one of those uh damn it i think
it was called stranger
and
the ammo it was a first person game the
ammunition was alive kind of similar to
this but this one seems to be way over
the top and now you know i play all
types of games man so i'm definitely
interested in this one you know i i give
it a try if i don't like it i uninstall
it
all right so this this next one now look
it's like i said with the kind of high
and light with me it's something i'm
gonna dabble in i don't know if i'm
gonna play like the full game but i'm at
least try and download it i know people
like to clown that feature and game pass
where people don't beat games that they
download but i'm all for it if i don't
like your game i feel like i didn't
spend zero interest
or investment into the game i can leave
at any time
i know bg loves to clown that aspect but
we we we're going to go to all riot
games uh coming to game pass now
it's the pc version it's not the full
game because a lot of riot games are
free to play now normally i wouldn't
really talk about this but i do feel
like this is a good move on the pc
portion because you know we love to to
clown on pc exclusive games because it
doesn't really appeal to a lot of
console exclusive games especially uh
the playstation demographic because they
have a lot more of you know third person
type of games and i don't really see
that on the pc bracket like that
but they have val valerant which is one
of the most popular games in the
industry right now believe it or not
they got a lot of those type of games
now they are breeding if you get game
pass pc or game pass ultimate you have
access to all of the operators kind of
like just to give you an example bg it's
like that free to play where you have to
buy the the character
or if you don't buy the character you
have i don't know if you can if there's
like season pass stuff it's like rainbow
six siege where every character you have
to uh purchase with in-game currency or
or real money now you get game pass you
get all of them off all their games and
i do feel like this is something that is
going to help them break in
to the
to the pc market a little bit because
you have the biggest games on pc
they're going to gravitate towards and
especially you know if they have certain
heroes that they don't want to commit to
pay 10 bucks one time and you can try
any of them that you want and i guess
they hoping it that leaks over into the
actual game pass itself with their first
party third party you know bg i want to
hear you on this because i feel like
this is something you don't give two
shits about
but i do feel like you can you can
understand why they would invest into
this
yeah i mean
it makes sense because they're trying to
bolster you know well it did you is this
going to uh game pass on pc because you
know yeah there are there are two
different things okay so yeah it it
makes sense um you know they're trying
to
uh you know support both game pass on
consoles and game pass on pc i don't
play any of these right
these games made by uh riot games um you
know i felt for a while like
um i'm aging out of the demographic that
they make multiplayer games for in a way
like
and and that feels that feels weird
because i'm not sure if i'm aging out or
they've completely changed the type of
multiplayer games that they used to make
that i think it's i think it's the
latter because like
from when you look at like
five you know uh
five to ten years ago the type of
multiplayer games they they make
um then are so different from the type
of multiplayer games they make now and i
want the ones they they made then
to come back so
yeah this
this it's a good it's a good move but
nothing nothing i care about i think
that when i hear you talk about i think
you like more down to earth everyone's
on the same level games i don't think
you like people having certain abilities
yeah i think the reason i like it is
because it puts an element on to it's
like not only are you playing players
you're playing their character too
uh so i think that's the reason i like
that's reason i like rainbow six siege
but dirt man like tell me like look this
is definitely one of those things there
i looked at this i wrote my eyes
uh i was like ain't nobody cared about
these games was the last time you in a
podcast people say i want val i actually
thought of uh of
valorent coming to xbox was about to
follow up on that unfortunately that
didn't happen uh but how did you feel
when you saw these because i actually
think it was a big deal
yeah well me personally i'm i'm not a pc
gamer at all
i've heard of the games and i've heard
how popular some of these games are
so um
one of my
partners on on like wbg he was like yo
this is a big deal and i said oh okay
then i saw the saw the games and i said
i guess it's good for you know xbox game
pass it makes business sense me
personally
i could care less personally but it
definitely makes sense
um for game pass on pc because like you
said these are popular games and um yeah
man that's all i got to say about that
is like you know yeah it makes sense but
i don't care you know i was kind of like
oh okay what's next you know like when i
saw it
all right so what we're gonna do
uh because um i don't want to go over
all these games we'll be here all day
let me get these super chats real quick
and then we'll go ahead and go over like
the big big games uh so we got a two
dollar super chat from flames starting
to think starfield is a pyramid scheme
oh jesus christ
we gotta fight all this scripture from
spartan ghost 17 what do you what are
your thoughts on star food imma be
honest quality range from good to
downright ps3 in that new atlas section
um
filament looked interesting to me uh
we'll get to start here in a minute man
and then we got a two hour super chat
from uh spartan ghost redfall looked mid
and show was mid i'ma be honest all
right man we'll get to that here in a
second all right so let's talk about
forza i don't care about forza i'm a
bureau with you
but even me not caring about forza i saw
this it was like that looked good
yeah it looked good so
how do you feel about this
i didn't look great man
um oh
oh like he might hate me just might not
i thought it looked good when they um
showed you know like we knew he's okay
turn ten usually do forza games for the
motorsport games every two years they've
had pretty much five and a half years
they're going to have five and a half
years with this game i thought it looked
absolutely incredible man i'm not i'm
over four as a horizon guy
but you better believe i'm going to play
this game um
oh man the graphics look great you know
is it me attic or were they talking a
little trash you know they're kind of
talking about that vehicle damage you're
talking about that in-game ray tracing
you know some of the things they were
saying and and it looks incredible to me
um it's kind of interesting that they
did have vehicle damage normally to my
understanding because i don't play these
things that really
they don't
they actual like people who make these
cars and stuff they don't like the
vehicle damage right uh so it was kind
of interesting that they uh they did
that i did a slow down close-up of the
vehicle damage they want you to see
the vehicle damage
so yeah i thought it looked good yeah i
actually felt like look like i'm not a
racing type of person but i felt like
look just what i saw obviously i don't
know that could be the worst racing game
in the world i wouldn't know it i don't
know anything about racing games but i
saw forza and i i was impressed but at
the same time i'm like man can we can we
move on like
like do we got to talk about this that
long i do feel like they spend a little
longer on a racing simulator bg
do you even want to make comments on
force
you're muted
my bad yeah forza forza to me is just
really good to look at you know i don't
like any racing game um
you know it they're it's literally just
eye candy i'm like every time a new
forza come out i'm like that looks
amazing so i would like i would like to
play it just to look at it
but you know that would fade that would
fade fast you know so that's all it is
to me
all right now we're going to talk about
um
we're gonna go down we're gonna try to
keep the first part we're gonna talk
about pendament i think that's how you
pronounce it
i ain't gonna lie to you i'm not gonna
say this game is a bad game because i'm
pretty sure it's gonna be a fun game but
when i saw this and i was vigilant what
obsidian was gonna make this wasn't it
like not even a little bit uh you know
let's start with dirt dirt yeah when you
first saw this game because i was i
ain't gonna lie i was a little
disappointed i i was like man i was like
i don't know because i played it but
that's not a game it looks like it would
appeal to me
yeah look the game
i'ma get a game and try right when it
comes out but
honestly man like i mentioned already
when i was watching the show
there was a down part of the show
i was like so my move was already going
down and then they showed that game you
know which is obviously xbox first party
i know
i knew it was a small game made by a
small team
but i was expecting you know like my boy
sean 786 said i was expecting like maybe
some 12 minute graphics you know some
just like a smaller game with some
better graphics
and when i saw that i was like what the
bro i was like is this pentamete is this
the what what and you know like i said
the game might be fine
it might be fun might have a deep story
but i was
let down with pentameter i just saw that
it didn't look rpg-ish i don't know
maybe i need to get out of this
mentality where i feel like a studio
needs to stick to what it makes good
like naughty dog i don't want them
making first person shoes all of a
sudden i don't want obsidian drifting
too far from you know rpgs that's why i
was a little disappointed grounded i'm
not gonna say this is gonna be a bad
game but when i when i looked at this i
was like this just doesn't look like
what i would want obsidian to do now
clearly
this is the type of game that gets 90
pluses and that's crazy like this
yeah that right it's just depends on the
scale of the game the story people like
a good story uh
bg i already know you was laughing at
this like this i already know you was
laughing at this i like obsidian but i'm
like this is this is below y'all and i
get like it's probably like a very small
team yes because they're working on like
three or four projects right now
um so i get it's probably like a very
small team that worked on it but
like who does this
who does this appeal to right i think i
think about it like you and you're right
these are the type of games that get 90
plus all metacritic but it's like okay
nobody really cares about it it'll
you know it's not
meant for
like i don't know who it's meant for
honestly and this is like it doesn't
look fun i'm like the visual the art
style i'm like
it's not even pleasing to look at
there's just nothing appealing about it
to me and i'm just like
y'all y'all could have done something
um
that would
that would have been more entertaining
um on a smaller scale a different genre
like you know a little small arcade game
that would have appealed to uh
to more gamers man i looked at this and
i was like i don't man i don't know what
this is
i'm not saying this isn't an rpg i don't
i don't think they released enough
information i know they did more stuff
in the extended show which let me read
with you guys i stuck on a 17 hour shift
i haven't watched that too too closely
started last night i'm going to sleep
so
i just don't when you think of obsidian
you think it's sick of truth you think
of knights of the old republic two you
think of the outer world you think of
fallout new vegas
and to some point grounded because i
mean even though that i don't think none
of us really play grounded it was a
successful game yeah it is a successful
game yeah but when i look at the pendant
it's just like
i just look at them like i just don't
see how how we get to this style game
it's not even really about the level
quality of the game it's just about like
what type of game is it because it
doesn't look like their type of game
yeah i mean that's how i felt so i was i
was really surprised i was oh this is
pentamen this is it you know i was
surprised like i was expecting something
a little
a little better but you know like i said
the game could be
dope
uh you know we obviously don't know but
yeah i was expecting something different
i mean at the end of the day
if they want to do these little passion
projects and they reward people for
you know making good games like the
outer worlds of valve then you let them
have the passion projects i just i do
think from here going forward when these
studios make fashion projects that's not
like the studio that they work for they
need to be a little bit more transparent
with that and i think that was the key
thing people didn't expect what they got
they expected a different type of game
yeah and and like you know passion
projects has almost
become an excuse for making a game that
nobody wants to play that's usually what
passion projects turn out to be it's
like yeah this small scale game that
you know
a few people on the team
are really excited to make
but it's really for them it's it's not
for
the gamers or the general audience
because they don't want it or they don't
care about it and they're not going to
play it so if you know like i i get
part of i can't be part of being a
developer is making a game that excites
you yeah but you're not making it for
yourself you're making it for an
audience and if the audience ain't gonna
care about it what's the point of making
it and let me ask a question with the
exception of uh grounded maybe what what
game has
i agree what you're saying um what game
what passion project has been a
tremendous success like a small
game like i know grounded is a success
you know it might not be our styling
game but it is a success i wonder i'm
trying to think these turned out was a
passion
yeah and i honestly felt like bleeding
edge didn't do well because it wasn't
properly supported they would have
delayed the game wasn't that bad yeah
six months to a year had a couple closed
betas made it into the preview program
took feedback from the community and
stopped making the game that you want to
play that you don't care if other people
want to play because i do think it was
slow i don't think it was as slow as
some people out there like people acted
like that was like to 10 frames per
second some people are naming like ori
is not a passion project or he has a big
budget behind it like that or he has a
lot of development behind it
minecraft might have been a passion
project but it's the exception not the
rule
like minecraft is a phenomenon among us
i get you i'll give you that among us i
will give you a fungus okay well that's
a good one there yeah yeah i'll give you
but i feel like a mungus had a
multiplayer feature and keep in mind
among this came out like a year and a
half before it blew up it was streamers
that took that game to the next level
and we're not we're not saying this game
isn't going to do good i'm just saying
from
an aspect of
playing obsidian games for the past
couple years i personally felt like it
didn't meet the expectation that i was
had in my head that that's a me problem
100 understand that that's a me problem
but when i looked at this game i'm like
i didn't see the rpg-ish in that i just
didn't and you know
let them make it because i i do feel
like if you consistently put out
good games who are we to say this game's
about to be good but i am i am agreeing
with bg a little bit just because the
developer wants that ideal on paper and
in a game form doesn't mean people are
going to buy it there's a reason that
people greenlight that don't green light
certain games because they don't see the
audience for and they don't see people
actually supporting that in terms of
finances but maybe something like game
pass lets them make these passion
projects because let's be real here if
if pendiment wasn't made it's not really
taken away from anything it was only
like what 10 15 people yeah yeah so it's
not like it was taking away from
anything but i do feel like
in terms of this game i look at it and
i'm just like
man i i could have used something else
like maybe a turn-based game because
they were they're known for those two
but it is what it is so yeah i mean the
game might be okay though you know like
it's supposed to be a deep deep
narrative so i'm definitely going to
give it a try though i might eat my
worries and love it you know you never
know
yeah i mean i i hope i eat my my my
words on that and it's like and it's
like we're not even saying the game's
bad it just when i look at it i'm just
like i just don't see the appeal maybe
it's because i need to watch that thing
in the uh the extended
uh microsoft show and i'll probably
watch that after the show but when i
look at i'm just like i guess that's
what it was i wanted something different
and that i have every right to want
something different chat i have every
right
all right so they talked about grounded
when it's originally coming out we don't
need to go into that too much it's cool
it's grounded you know i actually
probably won't play that with my
girlfriend uh because i feel like you
know she might like the the mechanics of
building stuff we got diablo four
yeah bg looks like your type of game
diablo 4. i
i think i've played a diablo game for
maybe a few minutes that's it you don't
like diablo games i have no insight on
on diablo what's your type of games this
is like third person action adventure
game
nah i mean listen i think the chat right
man they called y'all saying you only
like third person oh that's third person
that's an adventure i did it all i play
see i tell people all the time i play
all genres but it's very specific games
in the genres like i play age of empires
right
he does play that he does i play age of
empires i play x-com he doesn't play
that but i don't play any other game
like age of empires you know i'm saying
it'll always be
like one or two games in these more
obscure genres
that i that i play right it'll never be
like more than one of them like i've
played there's another game like that
plays like oh what's van helsing it's
literally plays just like diablo and
people would say you know
diablo is a way better
game than
like something like van helsing so why
don't you play diablo i don't know like
it's just that's just the way it it is
for me this is just very specific games
within the genre that i will play and i
won't play
a bunch of them because a bun all of
them just don't appeal to me so
you know
i actually
well how do you how do you feel about
dirt do you play these type of games um
i you know what
honestly um i never played the diablo
game like i said i know the last one was
on console like was the first two on
console
uh i don't know i don't know if two and
one was on call
yeah i remember three was on console but
i never tried it but this one looks very
interesting it looks uh i thought it
looked pretty good actually um
i'm definitely winning this ride man um
you know like whenever it comes out
so you know
all right i'm the type of guy i would
try any type of genre
i'll give it a try if i like it i like
if i don't i don't especially
considering hopefully by the time this
game comes out because it is next year
most likely it's going to be in game
pass so yeah yeah uh we got a 24 month
uh member chat from uh region g4 hashtag
iop hashtag
wbg and hashtag tts i don't know what
tts is talk that [ __ ] talk that's not
the podcast here's my boy sean parker oh
right oh rang g4 hey
yo what's up man i don't even see that
what's up bro and then we got a two
dollars for spartan go 17. y'all forget
that game pass isn't the hardcore i
agree with you i agree it and it's like
i said you know going back a little bit
to pendant like that's probably going to
resonate with a lot of people that's not
the type of gamer that is interested in
obsidian games and maybe that's the
overall goal is to open up their studio
to more people than just rpgs and i
don't even know this game i have some
rpg elements but when i looked at it it
didn't seem like that rpg type of game
that you would play oh let's let's talk
about this now i know me and bg probably
gonna like this guy i don't know about
you dirk i don't know about you
wulong fallen uh fallen dynasty all
right so apparently this is made by ex
developers that made
um the producer for
neo and the producer for bloodborne it's
supposed to be
a little bit faster than neo but not as
fast as something like like tekken uh
not tech attenu or however you pronounce
that game uh so
which is funny is i think neo is like
one of the fastest souls like games out
there
uh it's that's interesting it's because
i never play uh attention uh the game
that just went into game pass a whole
lot i think that's the game they're
comparing it to did you ever play that
bg oh you say
is that tenchu
not
back in the day but uh ninja gaiden i've
i played like one of ninja gaiden one of
the ninja gaidens i don't remember which
one it was i guess ninja gaiden is
ninja gaiden seems to be the person i
don't know it was it was either tincture
or a ninja game they were comparing it
to they're comparing the speed of the
game they said it's like midway between
one of those games and neo
so i'm kind of curious
if people are going to really gravitate
towards this game once it actually comes
out and keep in mind this is a very big
game that's coming in the game past day
and date like it's a third party
probably aaa type of game it's a team
ninja game i personally think if this
game works out well for them microsoft
needs the type of studio that makes
these type of games and i think i
honestly think that microsoft should
look at team ninja if this game does
well now clearly the final fantasy
fiasco game they just made recently uh
that was probably like the d team at
this point
you know they made that final fantasy
game and i don't think that game did
very well but i honestly feel like team
ninja is a good game and the reason i
would say that they might need to look
into that company buying them if they do
buy that anything related to that type
of genre is because
i honestly feel like from software
is a giant bag waiting to be bought and
i think sony will eventually buy them
because they have a good relationship
with them they've half of the from
software library is exclusive besides
the dark souls games
so it's just like to me
you want team ninja because you want to
make sure that if that goes that way
you still have access to decent games
clearly team ninjas know from software
that's just how it is but you could
build them to be somewhere close to them
but i feel like if they lose from
software eventually and that might not
ever happen but if they lose from
software
and team ninja was never bought like
let's say sony just goes crazy and buys
all games like that uh because i mean i
think you can uh you can agree bg that
that
that genre used to be small but
throughout the years it's gotten bigger
and bigger a little bit bigger and i
think that eldon ring has
has put that into the mainstream that
type of gameplay
yeah i mean i've i've beaten neo one and
two
um
i was hearing i wasn't i was hearing
that some people were a little unsure
exactly how this game is going to play
like some people were saying it might be
like one of those muzu games
um
but if if it's something like in the
vein of what they've made
uh you know recently then yeah i would i
would be interested in it um
but
because that you know they didn't really
show you know
like actual gameplay i i think it was
like kind of like
kind of cute
yeah
yeah so yeah i need to see some actual
gameplay
yeah considering that game's supposed to
come out at the beginning of next year i
feel like that's getting delayed we
didn't see no gameplay there's a reason
we didn't see gameplay like to me if you
show a trail and you say yo this game's
come out in six months to a year and we
don't see one liquid gameplay really in
that whole trailer what makes you think
i'm gonna believe you that game's
getting delayed
there's no way that game's coming i hope
i hope i'm wrong it's like i said you
know it's a very looks like it's going
to be a good game it's going to be in
game pass i think that's going to really
help microsoft give value to that
service i think it's a good thing man
you know because last generation you
know all of these types of games they
skipped xbox platform period they
skipped them period so to see that you
know it's on xbox and
in game pass that's a dope thing
also so yeah i mean i'm definitely uh
interested in this game see what's up
with it so
it's good to see them getting some more
of these types of games and on the xbox
platform
yeah and the next one i know bg don't
care about this game yeah we've said
that like almost every game but we're
going to move on
personas persona's coming together to
game pass and coming to the xbox
platform with game pass i think this is
probably the
the announcement that was the biggest to
me by far uh for those of you that's
been watching iop for those of you
that's been seeing my uh public outcries
i've literally been crying about this
for like a year and a half or two i want
persona where's persona i want persona
uh clearly we're still missing final
fantasy vii uh
tomorrow's comment bro is that comedy
i don't know we're gonna talk about that
here in a second because there's some
weird stuff going on out there we're
gonna talk about here in a second but
you know persona coming to the platform
there's not really a whole lot to talk
about that i do think it's good for the
xbox platform to finally start getting
these kind of games absolutely obviously
it's like five years late then they come
out like 2016 or something like that
i mean geez like some wars have been big
some wars have fought in these amount of
time that we got persona
it is what it is it's just like look
i love that they got this but microsoft
if you don't get persona 6 into your
platform day and date not game pass into
xbox and you don't get you know
hopefully the next final fantasy don't
know if that's gonna happen or the next
dragon quest what's the point in getting
the predecessors
i don't think there's a point in that
you have every final fantasy almost
known to man on on xbox now but we ain't
getting 16. we ain't getting final
fantasy 7 part 2 and we ain't getting
final fantasy vii part one i don't know
what's gonna happen tomorrow they could
announce it there's gonna be some type
of event tomorrow probably not i'm gonna
be real with you guys we got five dollar
super chat from trey bone 408s we're not
the only hardcore gamers there's others
that are hardcore but for different
genres not every game is for people who
want mature games always i i definitely
uh understand that point
to a little bit that's definitely true
and then we got a
we got a
10 months a 10 month chat from lucius
augustus shout out to bg i may not agree
with the united states at the time but i
typically respect where you're coming
from salute to addict and dirt
all right so let's let's go ahead and uh
absolutely
yeah so let's go ahead and talk about
the kojima thing
you guys know
been watching iop you know i'm not a fan
of kojima like not even a little bit
uh you know i even make jokes sometimes
saying that he belongs in a straight
jacket because of the stuff that man
says in his mind is he he he's like i
always felt like he would do better in
the in in in the cinematic universe
making movies making tv supposed to be
doing that isn't he yeah that's what i
feel like he should be doing uh i know
bg you right there with me you're not a
big fan of uh kojima
i'm a fan of um
uh you know everybody knows i hated
death stranding um i'm a fan of his
previous games you know of course most
people like metal gear
um i'm just not a fan of how he how he
moves he's a
i think he he wants to be a director in
uh for movies more than absolutely a
game developer that's why like
you know in-depth stranding he has all
these a-list whatever select whatever
list celebrities they are the game is
just full of celebrities right um you
know acting and everything like that
and you know he just he's he's just full
of himself like and the industry
the industry parades him around that way
that's why he acts like that like
whatever whatever developer you know
could show up to a conference
announce nothing
but they they act like he just dropped
the megaton like he literally showed up
it's like somebody said it was like that
that i don't know if you that um that
sailor moon um meme where the dude shows
up
and he's like you're welcome and he and
she's like you didn't do anything that's
literally what happened mom you just
showed up showed face and did nothing
and like
and left i'm like bro he did something
bg
um
you know well first off let me say this
um i'm not a huge fan of him but i did
like his previous games i hated his last
two games i did not like dev stream i
did not like motor girl solified but i
enjoy all of the previous metal gear
games one two three and four
uh but you know i understand he's a
legend in the industry but what he did
um
to me
now this is just for my xbox fanboy mine
he proved a lot of people wrong
that's what he did for me now i
understand what everybody say hey he
even he hit like he didn't announce the
game well he announced they announced
that he's working on the game for xbox
exclusively he's probably still making
the playstation game at the same time um
but a lot of people said this would
never happen
a lot of people said there's no way in
hell
kojima is going to make an exclusive
game for xbox
i have receipts
i mean i i kevin for years you got a
folder in your phone for for a unique
situation don't you it's like it's all
you receive is all your receipts in one
photo do you got multiple folders for
different multiple folders with receipts
and listen i'm being 100 honest with you
i had a
kojima would not make an xbox exclusive
folder
because
when we heard the rumor i said you know
jeff grubb seems to be a reliable guy
so after he announced that people to
start nowhere here and i actually did a
video about it i didn't say one word in
the video i just played music and showed
the receipts um so it it was funny to me
because guys are saying it would never
happen
so that's the only reason why i really
enjoyed it now i'm interested to see
what type of game it would be well i
like it who the hell knows but
you know he is a creative guy
and i think actually the super chat i'm
gonna read it real quick because it has
a lot to do with what we're talking
about uh two super chat from spartan
ghost 17.
uh kojima got good ideas but can't write
to save his life i actually think that
is the very good accuracy when it comes
to him
he has good ideas to to evolve the
industry good features he could put in
games
but he can't i just didn't
i don't see that coming good in terms of
gameplay you know what i'm saying like
because you got to do there's there's
difference between making a tv show and
a movie then making a game you gotta
have interaction between the player and
the actual product you gotta have a good
way of telling a story through 40 hours
to 20 hours plus depending on how long
the game is you know that amount of time
throughout that whole time you got to be
able to keep the players interest be
able to slowly earn stuff to make them
man being a developer sucks
it's just like so bg i know
you know you you don't have an xbox or
anything like that uh do you think that
just him being up there was big for the
xbox brand like showing that they are
working with uh people like kojima
i can't really think it it
it did anything for xbox other than
um maybe
partially upset some some fanboys um you
know some some blaze asian dudes who
for some reason would be mad that he's
making an xbox game i
i can't but i don't think it did any
anything else because like a kojima game
isn't gonna
you know move the needle um for xbox i
think in in
one way or another so you know it's a
good thing to have but like i said i
me personally like like i said i didn't
like death stranding i didn't like mgs5
i think kojima needs a handler to keep
him in check he's a little bit insane
um i agree with that so
yeah it didn't do anything for me
all right so
we're gonna go and move on to uh there's
a couple little topics before we go into
the starfield stuff you know the
extended i don't really want to go over
too much of that because i didn't really
watch that but if you dirt you want
because i'm sure you watched it if you
want to go over specific announcements
that we can hear in a second i want to
talk about this thing that just went out
on twitter so for those of you know
there's this true insider i'll call him
man he's the only playstation insider
that's ever been right on anything and
his name is the snitch
yeah
yeah so he's been
100 so far
so it's interesting because final
fantasy is having a
like an event tomorrow i'm sure you know
about fiji um so they're having one uh
they and they're hyping this up this is
the first time i've ever seen square
enix hype up this type of stream
like they've been doing nothing but
tweet about it so the stitch being the
snitch
he tweeted a picture of zach
cloud and aerith with zach and cloud on
the right earth on the back looks like
some kind of uh crisis core picture now
keep in mind this this might not be
crisis core because of all the stuff
that happened in the remake this might
be something that is in part two i don't
know but what's more interesting is at
the top of it it has a blue square
a red square and a black square and a
green square
uh so this is probably crisis core
because it's the only thing i can feel i
can run on the switch that's just my
personal opinion so if crisis score
comes out and it is on that because
there's a green square
if it comes on the xbox
that's interesting because to me
seeing final fantasy on xbox in any way
shape or form right now gets me excited
what do you guys feel about this uh do
you think that
we're trying to figure out
what what is really the
point in bringing crisis
to like current platforms right now
though like
because it might
i think that
part two is going to go different way
than people think
and i think
i personally okay spoiler for remake
came out years ago not my fault
zack is alive at the end of it
so i think they want to introduce newer
audiences to zach
because he's alive in it uh so i think
that's the reason that they would bring
it back keep in mind this might be a
part two i don't know how part two would
fit on a switch
but we're gonna roll with it might be a
steam version
if it was part two why would he
highlight zach you know
no because zach's alive and powerful
yeah yeah but still like
okay but if they bring part two to like
all these platforms you would assume
part one is coming also
what they might announce that i don't
know yeah but it was highly rumored it
was coming out even rant said it was
supposed to come out but it never got
announced and that's the thing like if
i'm teasing that it's part one and part
two
coming to all these platforms i'm just
not necessarily gonna use
zach like that's oddly specific to you
zach you know what i'm saying like yeah
we know he's alive um in the in the
remake but that's very specific you know
to highlight zach that's all i'm saying
yeah and plus if you didn't play the
first one you wouldn't know that he who
he even was anyway unless you play the
old games it's a dirt i know that we
talk about you know xbox needs to do
better and highlighting these older
games
and give them to their platform
maybe this is a publishing thing where
square enix can get away with doing it
um it's interesting that if this isn't
if this is a publishing thing
maybe
sony
had that their exclusive game deals has
ran out
because it's just interesting that this
game might be coming to xbox not even
about the game
it's about the fact that we didn't get
part one we didn't get pretty much every
square enix game that came out in the
past couple years that wasn't made
before then that has came out is going
to be
nowhere near the xbox platform
but the snitch put that green box in
there which makes me think that maybe
that deal that square enix and
playstation has made is over
i guess it's possible man you know we've
um
we've heard for years that phil spencer
would be going back and forth to japan
for whatever reason
and i know phil spencer um has heard
a lot of xbox fans say yo man why is all
of these games skipping the xbox why are
all these games you know like nowhere
near the xbox obviously you know they
still have work to do
but it's i think it's good to see some
of these games coming to the xbox
platform like i'm not really interested
me personally but
i mean how can you uh you know
like not say this is a good thing now as
far as the deal
it seems like possible maybe those deals
do have exploration data i'm not sure
but it seems like maybe they do i mean
every contract has an explanation date
right
eventually right so uh yeah it depends
if it's game wise or years wise like
most of the time these are game wise
because it could take years to make if
you make a deal for ten years that
theoretically that's only like three
games you know what i'm saying right so
and then not to mention if you get into
situations like the pandemic that 10
years might turn into two games because
games are delayed yeah absolutely so
yeah it's it's a good thing man um
you know
that's all i can say because i you know
i don't know much about the franchise
honestly
i'm just going back to what you guys
have said it's never been on my xbox by
one or two s has there been a part two
or you guys said this there's one part
one was
coming from the ps4 and ps5
uh part two hasn't been announced yet uh
we did get final fantasy like the older
ones seven eight nine ten
twelve that's on the xbox now i remember
but it does seem the past couple years
of the majority of the games now their
last square enix is they had uh
strangers of paradise that's like the
team ninja game i was clowning on
earlier that did show up on xbox but
that was their last game
for spoken isn't on xbox right uh final
fantasy 16 isn't on xbox
what's funny square enix published games
that don't go on xbox like triangle
strategy but that's not on playstation
either
so it's going to be interesting to see
if
uh 15 was on xbox uh but that's been
years ago like 2011 that was that was
2015 maybe 15. yeah yeah that's 15 years
ago seven years ago
we ain't really got something since then
chrono cross
i i see you i see but we're talking
about final fantasy because that's
what's been really staying away
is those final fantasy teams
so all right i know bg you don't care
about fallout games
about fallout no
listen i think we finally found out why
he don't like xbox i tried bro i tried
fallout 3 that was the first fallout
game i tried i was like this game is
terrible i don't know how people like
this then i was like you know what let
me let me when fallout 4 came out i was
like let me try this again you know
maybe it was just to retried that still
hated it i was like yeah this ain't this
this series ain't for me
hey um
can i say something that's exactly
that's exactly what happened with me
i tried fallout 3 was the first one i
tried i didn't care for it on the on the
360.
bought fallout 4. you know obviously
this was like before the does any mess
acquisition
is it's not for me this is not for me
i get that and you know fallout's not
for everyone just like pretty much
bethesda games in general are for
everyone yeah but what i find
interesting is i guess todd howard must
have slipped up a little bit i don't
know if he intentionally said this or
not uh but he did kind of say we're not
making a fallout five until otis gross
six and we're not getting elder scrolls
six to probably 20 25 20 26 at the
earliest
i so it literally might be i might be 40
years old
before we get a fallout 5.
i know you guys don't care about that i
know follow if i don't have to show up
but to me maybe it's because
microsoft sees
the
catalog that they have they got the uh
elder scrolls sticks coming out they got
uh the outer worlds two they got avowed
uh they got star filled
they're excellent and that's how they're
making yeah maybe they look at that it's
like we don't necessarily need fallout
because we're having all these other
ones but i disagree
i feel like fallout
fallout is such a huge
franchise
to not give
the community that game is it's not
disrespectful but it's not it's not a
good look man like you need to work with
bethesda
get people they trust and let them make
their own team
outsource i don't care what you got to
do you can because if you start in 2024
2025 on a fallout 5 when the elder
scrolls thing starts dying down you're
not going to see a fallout 5 until
probably 20 20
20 30 20 31
like and that's why i'm like
you can't make me wait eight years for a
fallout game so you're saying they need
to somehow build another team
or out outsource
for fallout 5.
i actually i'm a big fan of
co-development i think obsidian and
bethesda should work on fallout together
uh you know have a couple people from
each side come together and form a new
team
and i think that would be the best
output i mean i would love obsidian
and bethesda software studios co-develop
the game that would be the craziest
stuff ever
uh how do do you think they should do
that bg you think uh fallout for the
bushes man who cares about fallout i
mean listen uh the only thing close to
fallout i did really like i played outer
worlds and i loved outer worlds man yeah
i enjoyed it damn that's funny like we
got different tastes but it's i love all
the wars also though yes it's so weird
because the people would say out you
know outer worlds is similar to fallout
right
but
i think i think fallout sucks and i
think out of worlds is great so
you know
that's what's going on see now the thing
with me though um i don't know about you
guys i'm much older than you guys i
matured as a gamer like games like uh
the witcher 3
like i finished the witcher 3 i loved it
i put like 200 hours in the assassin's
creed valhalla i would have never done
that back when i was you guys age
so i kind of matured so maybe i would
give fallout another chance
um like again i never played the elder
scrolls game at all i'm definitely going
to give it a try but
me personally maybe i will give those
games to try more with the open mind but
i try to do that with fallout 4 i just
didn't like it but
um so i see what you guys are saying uh
like i love outdoors like you did so it
was kind of weird i didn't like fall out
but i love the outer worlds and i'm
looking forward to other worlds too so
and i think a lot of that has to do is
like outer worlds gives you a little bit
of freedom but
it doesn't let you it doesn't like
they give you freedom but on a leash if
that makes sense like they kind of
direct you where you go
they they do give you the options of
telling different stories by having
options but they don't be like
just cut the leash just go do what you
want to do they kind of give you an
infrastructure that you do you know they
don't let you go to any planet you want
from the from the get-go you've got some
planets you've got to work up to and i
think that might be the reason people
like the outer wards because you still
get that feeling of the fallout
franchise but you don't get that you're
just wild and you go anywhere you want
to feeling
right
all right so let's let's go ahead and
get to the meat potatoes man star filled
and red fall
uh we'll start with red fall i will say
one thing uh bg what was your
expectations of right fall going into
this and uh what what was the outcome
when you saw this gameplay
like would you say that out loud you
think i like
one well
they're kind of different like artwork
too i don't think it's really about the
graphics
exactly like nobody it's not i'm not
gonna dislike fallout so you think so do
you think i would like fall out if it
had better graphics no i still wouldn't
like fallout because of the gameplay so
i just want to i'm like that comment
made no sense i i'm like y'all gotta say
stuff out loud
before y'all type it and realize how
stupid you all sound sometimes
um
but
red fall um
honestly i always thought the game was
just gonna be uh
i thought it was gonna be back for blood
with vampires and that's what i still
think it's going to be i think this
thing is going to be back for blood with
vampires you know with with i think
maybe a little bit more creative
abilities
i'm not into
really the co-op shooters
i think some i think some people said
this is actually might be a looter
shooter i think so i can't remember i
don't know i don't know if they said a
little shirt i don't remember
i don't know like maybe it is maybe i
can't remember exactly but i'm not into
the co-op you know the co-op you know
first-person shooters
uh i don't think
most people are really into them anymore
i think
people really play them for like
three weeks to a month and kinda drop
them
because they
games developers have been trying to
recapture
uh left 4 dead
since left 4 dead and nobody's been able
to do it right nobody has been able to
have the longevity of left 4 dead
there's been several games that have
tried to
recreate the formula and all of them
just haven't lived up to it um yeah i
know you could play it solo like you
know it's not necessarily something you
have to play with friends but i think
it's one of those games that's that's
designed
for you to play with friends and
it's just not
it's just not my my you know my type of
uh
my type of game and i i think it's uh
yeah it's just not really that that
appealing you know but it's not doing
anything for me i do think that like
because they are a little bit of um
rpg mechanics that's in back uh back for
blood but i do think this rpg's gonna be
a little bit more centered
in this game i i
there was um
an exclusive interview that uh someone
sent me on twitter i still ain't got to
watch it because i literally woke up
almost went straight into this i need to
watch that but what i will say about
this is regardless we did see like skill
trees and stuff like that i i wish they
would have been a little bit more open
with that
during the main show like be a little
more vocal and what separates this from
games like that and i think that was the
biggest problem with this um you know
the abilities is nice i like the the
chick that that had the like the
elevator thing i will say that
the way they described the elevator in
that cgi scene scene last year and the
way it worked didn't really do one for
one to me it seemed like it was
something that would go up not shoot you
up you know what i'm saying like it felt
like something trampoline yeah
and i kind of was disappointed about
that but what i will say about red fault
is i came in here with almost no
expectations on this game
and i left
be like okay maybe i'll try it you know
what i'm saying like like you look at my
reactions on the iron lures podcast
channel i was like oh
because it just it first off look is it
the the best looking game ever no but i
don't think it looks bad by any means
uh you know maybe
i felt like the blood could have been
dripping at the beginning when it was on
the ceiling fan i felt like it could
have been dripping but that's little
details that go a long way but it's
never been that end-all be-all for me so
i i do think that this is going to be a
good game for people who want to play
with their friends
one of the things that i've noticed when
it comes to game pass is really nice to
to be able to sell someone something
without them having to really buy it
just sub the game pass download reform
will play and i think that's what really
got me is the fact that i had such low
expectations for the game when i looked
at it i was like man this game actually
looks pretty good uh dirt you'll be
playing this game
absolutely man first off let me say this
i am a huge fan of arcane
i love the designer series i love pray
i love their games and if you have a
studio that you trust
you know you just you know you just
trust them right um you know like like
most people trust naughty dog you know
they know they're gonna make a great
game
some people you know trust whoever like
and i trust arcane so arcane's a good
studio yeah i love i love this honor i
love it
i love all of the like both of the
designers i love the dlc
i love pray and i believe this arcane
austin is a team that may pray so
um they're doing this game now let me
tell you something death loop was a good
game too yeah i haven't played it yet uh
you know i have my ps5 and now i'm just
going to wait until it comes to spots
but let me say this
um
when we saw the cgi trailer last year so
this looks interesting but you just
don't know what to expect right
so see an actual gameplay i thought it
looked dope i thought it looked dope now
this is my opinion i feel this is a
single-player game with co-op i think
they're trying to push the co-op but
there were some things said by pete
hines yesterday to make me think this is
a single-player game
that your friends can play with you also
um i actually have the opposite opinion
i think the call-up game that they say
you could play by yourself
if it's the first a single player game
with co-op
right i probably will have more interest
in it only because
the single-player games you know with
co-op
tend to rely on actually developing a
fun game while co-op games
tend to rely on the fun just being of
the fact that you're playing with your
friends right i agree with that yeah
well like this is just my opinion
you know i think
it's
a single-player game with co-op you know
and of course if you've seen the the
like recent news
um you know if you play co-op
the only person story
progresses is the host
um to me that's a giveaway that that one
pushed a lot for being a single-player
thing but yeah that's why i think so i
feel like we've seen that stuff in like
um state of decay if i remember
correctly like it goes off the side
player too yeah he does he does but i
personally feel like
if that's the case
they're really pushing co-op i feel like
if you push a single-player game that's
the single like you don't really you
show co-op games but it's one of those
things that's like the side thing if you
want to see the co-op game game play go
watch it
over here we got a youtube video but i
feel like they've always highlighted the
co-op experience of the game and i feel
like a game
depending on how they market is what the
game was designed to do and to me
they've always marketed as a co-op
experience game
pete hines saying that was like the only
time i've ever heard them really try to
act like this game can be played in a
single player fashion that would be fun
i'm not saying it's not going to be fun
i just feel like like bg said if a game
is designed for a co-op experience they
expect you to play with game with other
people the only game i've ever played
without us a buddy was like resident
evil 5. it was annoying but it was
tolerable
but that game was definitely designed
for you have another person because he
would get killed by like puzzles like
you know the laser puzzle if you had a
an ai sometimes he wouldn't go to a spot
on the map that would keep him alive and
you would tr you would rotate the little
laser thingy to kill him every time so
it's like features like that that was
put in the game that's clearly a co-op
experience type of game but when you
play the game as a single player game
you could play i see like resident evil
hopefully
you know brett fault is that type of
game now most likely i'm going to play
this with other people
but i that that doesn't really bother me
too much um you know i prefer a co-op
game being made from the ground up to be
something like it takes two
resident evil five residents not even
resident evil six something that that
acknowledges the other person is there
like in resident evil 5 you had to like
like twist a little thing backwards and
you had to do a lot of stuff that
required two people and they'd done it
well like i said resident evil 5 was one
of the very few games i felt like was
built from a co-op experience that you
could play by yourself you just there's
a couple places in the game that annoy
you uh but you know
let's go ahead and talk about star field
okay we're going to end up with star
field you guys know i don't like keeping
people here long i like to get to the
point and get out mm-hmm i like that we
got we we got a lot of uh we got a lot
of things that i've brought up man if
there's anything that's happened
people has talked about starfield
all right so let's let's go over these a
little bit man first off let's talk
about what's your general thoughts when
you saw the game play you know
expectations going here i feel like
starfield was definitely by far the most
high
expectations when it come to this
trailer it was we got we got a story
trailer last year with not a whole lot
of game play any game play actually and
now we're going into this uh so first
off i'm going to start with uh dirt when
you watch this what was your general
expectation now keep in mind this is
when we're seeing the uh the
stuff that hasn't been compressed we
haven't seen four crate trailers nothing
like that so it's just the live stream
what was your your initial thoughts
my initial thoughts was it looked good
it looked good it looks like it's going
to be a massive game
um i like you know highlight most but
there's the games you could do third
person or first person i thought the gun
play looked decent um you know like
especially for a game a year out
i i thought it looked fine you know um i
would say i was kind of excited for it i
want to see more about the game
you know a lot of customization um you
know yeah so i think my first thoughts
my
initial thoughts was it looks great
what about you bg i know that you're not
the biggest fan of these type of games
uh did star foot look like it might it
might move you
uh
no um it's definitely not something i'm
buying it's funny like the
there there's a bunch of bethesda games
that i like they just showed all the
ones that
i don't like well under the bethesda
umbrella you like like
i like wolfenstein i like dishonored
don't you know i like um
uh evil within i actually one of the
reasons that i really resp uh like i
constantly push for like death loop is i
wanted to make a dishonored three so
it's just like
you know i like that so definitely it
was a good game but it's like give me
that dishonored three i love dishonored
great games yeah you know
even like ghost wire tokyo but like the
i guess the you know the the fallout and
the skyrims that's the part of bethesda
like and that's i guess that's the main
part of bethesda that's the part i don't
like um
and you know i so starfield
yeah i'm not i'm not into you know the
whole space exploration type of games
besides outer worlds that's the only
exception um
and you know
i think the game looking at it and needs
like
another
i mean they have another i think it
should launch next year in the fall
at the earliest right you know i don't
think so
just out of curiosity bg what about that
made you think it needed like obviously
the performance it was kind of lacking
there i'm kind of can't like i might ask
people that do stuff like this like why
they let games that perform bad be on
the showcase maybe it's like a time
structure thing they don't have enough
time to properly like because what i've
been told like the performance stuff
that's done after the whole game's done
pretty much but it's like to me
i'd rather you work like cut that slice
out of the game and make sure that
portion runs functional then put it on a
stage looking like it's 10 15 frames
like i know that maybe that's
unrealistic in the type of a development
world i don't know anything about that
but all i do know is you had a bunch of
people looking at this saying yo the
game looks cool but what's that frame
for remember scale bound
yeah it's
it's
the tech it's the technical things that
i think um is going to require them
um a lot of time to clean up because you
know there was a lot of technical
hitches and things um you know a lot of
the fine details like him shooting the
the i don't know what they are the
pirates space pirates and some of them
not reacting at all they didn't even
have an animation to be uh animation for
getting shot some people don't care
about that small stuff right but you
know
one of the i'm very particular about
shooters
that
you know when i shoot
an enemy i want like to see like
visceral reactions that's one of the
reasons why like wolfenstein is like
probably i would say currently my
favorite um first person shooter because
like when you shoot enemies it's just so
impactful right i want to say that
it didn't look like there's a lot of gun
recoil and i will admit that there
wasn't a lot of blood someone brought
that yeah
i didn't see blood at all actually like
and that's and i think because it's more
rpg than an actual shooter right yeah it
is definitely you get that from from
rpgs they will some enemies won't
actually react to being being shot there
won't be blood and you know
that that comes with certain rpgs and i
think like you know there was some
technical you know like you said the
frame rate uh some you know some people
were zooming in okay about stuff you
gotta you know zoom in 100 times on but
there was like a lot of technical stuff
and the game is obviously unfinished but
i think anytime for me anytime i hear a
developer
say
this is our biggest most ambitious game
ever
that that's that's a red flag to me not
like it's a red flag it's a
it's a red flag because
what comes with that is usually
the bigger the game is the more
typically the more bugs there are that's
just that's just math that that's how it
that's how it goes right because you're
including more things in the game yeah
more than they get in the side yeah more
things go wrong so the bigger you make
your game
the more time you need to actually fix
any little bugs that may appear here and
there more technical problems here and
there you need a lot of time
you know to fix mechanics that may not
work it could be a million things you
know and that's what you know i worry
about when they say they're making
something so ambitious you know more
than they ever made before that comes
with a lot of challenges so you know um
all right that's what i think they need
to you know really work right so i i
asked you dirt so now let's let's move
to the the combat a little bit because
we've talked about the graphics now we
can bring up the graphics a little bit
in the combat i do feel like the combat
looked a little bit outdated to me uh
but then again i it's hard to really
know how a game feels in terms of first
person until you actually play it but it
did look like it was outdated and i felt
like the graphics weren't like eye candy
but they weren't the greatest either you
know they weren't horrible they weren't
eye candy and i think the issue we're
having here is this isn't an xbox one
game it's a series s and x game so i i
do feel like people have her the right
to expect it to look better because it
is a next-gen only game how you feel
about that dude you think that you think
that's being a little unrealistic or you
think because it is a next-gen game you
can't have more expectations for a game
first off it's the xbox game it doesn't
matter what consoles it's on
it's xbox exclusive game
so you know there's going to be
microscopes on the morning if this game
was a multiplayer like do you think
you'll be scrutinized as much as it's
been
honest question
it just depends on what type of game it
is cd projekt red problem no no
there is a game no
game play if it was a multiplayer would
it be scrutinized as much as it's being
i'm saying it would if it was a
different developer i'm i get what you
said on xbox like i think a lot of
people is always gonna you know get yeah
they've always got that kind of heat but
i do feel like you're getting it because
it is like now look 76 kind of
dulled down the bethesda brand a little
bit where it's not as many people
defending as they used to be but like
fallout 4ish
you was getting that heat because it was
by beloved french company such as
bethesda now you're getting into the
starfield territory where there's still
those people there but then you're
adding the exclusive on xbox thing so
it's getting heat from that side too i
think it's getting hit with a double
whammy thing i would say there's a lot
more people
upset because it's an exclusive but i do
think there are some valid criticism
there i do think there is valid
criticism of people having issue with
the way it looks and the combat and and
part of it is you know once again um
it's
when you when you go you know on twitter
and you hear people talk about star
field it's it's the same thing that i
had you know had the problem with with
cyberpunk you know
um not saying this game is going to turn
out light cyberpunk that's not not what
i'm saying i'm saying is prior to
cyberpunk releasing you had people
saying the same thing
about cyberpunk that they're saying
about and that's what i was saying
certain studios get this energy
regardless if it's exclusive and that's
the prop sometimes the fans are the
downfall of the game
because you have fans saying this is
going to be the greatest game ever it's
going to be the greatest rpg ever it's
going to be you know
this amazing fantastic groundbreaking
revolutionary game i'm like bro can
y'all realize if y'all didn't set this
game up so high
then maybe the expectations wouldn't be
so high like that i don't think people
realize that like
that this it's i agree with you why why
games are so highly criticized i i will
agree with you in terms of us hyping up
a game we do do that a lot i mean we do
with everything god of war movies tv
shows it doesn't matter but i will say
them coming out we're about to talk
about saying uh you know thousand
planets
you know you could build your ship and
then and i love how tall howard said oh
and yes you could fly the ship so you
know we'll get into that in a minute i
feel like
generating statements like that
obviously that could be part of the game
but you didn't really need to say it had
a thousand planets you know what i'm
saying like you could have said it has a
mass universe that you could explore get
the same point across but now people are
like oh it's got a thousand planets
let's go well we don't even really know
anything about the thousand plants we
don't know if half of them are going to
be in liverpool clearly not every planet
in starfield is going to have life on it
because not every planet in the in our
galaxy has planet on it but it is to a
point where you know we'll go into the
thousand pla planets real quick right i
do feel like people have
a
a realistic
thought process and to be like
cool you have a thousand planets but how
many of those are we realistically going
to play with how many of those are we
realistically going to have already said
a lot of them are going to be banned
already said that
at that point
are they even
it's different having how many are
banned like we're talking 25 35
in my opinion it's the same as any other
game you know the the like the brand new
nba 2k we added a thousand new
animations thing that you play i agree
with animations
but i do feel like i do feel like the
you know we'll put in a little bit the
you can't enter with ships you can't
enter like i guess it's going to like
you get close enough to a planet the the
ship is going to just like have you
naturally land and they're going to give
you likes
that you can lay it i don't know i
didn't really go too much into it too
much uh but apparently you can't like
enter the atmosphere or something like
that i don't know they said that wasn't
important i don't really care about that
either but to
me starfield's always been kind of hyped
to you on the exploration of the game
now a thousand planets is fine a lot of
them bear it's fine but we still have to
have some kind of environment some kind
of energy even if a planet is is empty i
still expect to do something on that
empty planet for instance
mass effect how many times in the
original mass effect that they clearly
throughout the franchise fixed
like you can't even really go to planets
like that in mass effect 3
like you can but there's not a lot of
them uh and then in mass effect 2 they
even limited even more that was a mass
effect one my only fear is
you'll have about
a thousand percent of them or maybe 50
planets you have something to do on you
know what i'm saying like at that point
you know that's just me that's me
reaching but they didn't really give me
a lot of details on what we're going to
be doing these plans either so i can
only do it but speculate
like that's my only fear and that's why
i feel like people have the right to to
sense that now obviously if you generate
quests you generate you know different
kind of landscapes kind of like what
they do on on
on no man's sky which is funny they
compared this game hard core to no man's
sky but me coming from the person
playing these type of games i just don't
want fluff added on the game i would
prefer 50 to 100 planets
that they put fine detail in
then a thousand planets that most of
them aren't going to be anything
relevant or you do anything we don't
know we don't know the game we ain't
playing the game
but we do have to go off what they're
telling us people keep saying mods in
the chat if you guys don't calm your ass
down
i ain't trying to have someone else fix
the game i buy yeah that's nuts yeah
look that's gonna add cherry on top but
keep in mind
a lot of uh some of this war i don't
know how much they really go into detail
on that
it's generated it's randomly generated
so can you really mod something that the
actual game randomly generates i don't
know i'm not a modder but there's a lot
of speculation going on to this we we we
need to know more information i think
that's the biggest thing what i saw on
star field
it was it was enticing it made me
interested but i can honestly say that i
felt more comfortable with red fall
coming out of this event than i did
starfield because i know what we expect
on red fall they
they went in starfield
it felt like
they showed a little bit of everything
but they didn't give enough information
on anything
like they talked about the character
creation tool in there but they didn't
show you really like a lot of the the
mods or anything on there like i kind of
want to see the stat system maybe the
level up system they really go into
detail on any of that
and you know maybe it was in the extent
but but
i mean it's a much it's a much bigger
game than rare fall um you know so i
mean that maybe that's one reason why
they show why you feel more confident by
rare i don't know i'm not sure i'm i'm
sure there's a reason they couldn't show
everything uh about starfield that you
know what i was really what i really
liked about is the the space combat you
know for those who don't know the chat
you can actually make your own ship
which i like you can make your own bases
that kind of return from fallout 4. i
like i'm not see the chat said you're
saying i'm being like downer that's my
problem with sometimes in this community
you can't even bring up stuff that
you're curious on and you're concerned
about where people say that you're
hyping something up too much or you're
being low down on too much like look
i see a thousand planets i don't
automatically assume that's amazing i
say yo that's cool but what can we do
with those thousand planets that's all i
asked now you guys can take that
narrative spin it all you want saying
i'm speaking too negative about
something that's fine
but i'm just looking at this and i'm
like
how much of this world is
is realistically going to contribute to
the story that's all i want to know how
much is this universe because we have
you know it's not like it's just random
concern we have
you know things we can point to where
developers brag about oh it's a huge
world you know it's
you know it has all it you know they
they boast
numbers but
large games is is it's really
never really about the number it's about
the density
you know like you can have a thousand
planets and once again we don't know
what's what's on them they said some of
it is going to be
procedurally generated but it's really
all about the density you know when it
comes to sandbox or open world games so
you know that's what really matters but
developers are always going to
brag these vague arbitrary numbers that
don't necessarily mean anything and you
know what's crazy when i when i bring up
my concerns when i play god of war and
there's too many trolls and you know the
boss fights weren't is as crazy as that
i wanted to be
a lot of people don't have an issue of
me having those statements but the
moment i criticize star field
i feel like everyone comes out of every
it's like it's like that that meme where
the dude's in the middle and all the
swords and guns are pointing out i'm
like dude i want starfield to be great i
played all of fallout new vegas i played
fallout 3. i played
all of these games man
i want it to be great me just vocalizing
my concerns with the game doesn't mean
that's going to be a bad game you know i
honestly feel like you could spend years
just flying around if there's really a
thousand that looked like it kind of
like
had a hub thing
where it's like
you could go to the certain galaxies
that's going to be fine and i don't
think the game is going to be bad it's
just i
voicing my concerns bethesda please have
a lot to do in this world this game
that's all i'm saying i'm not saying
it's not going to have it i'm just
saying please
have a lot to do in the game now someone
said that todd howard confirmed that
there will be a deep dive on the planet
soon that's fine as long as they answer
my questions before the game comes out
then we're good
but i just want stuff to do in the game
i don't want to be like go to a world
and they ain't nothing to do there i
want the space combat to be very
in-depth i want the factions to be in
depth i want to be true cruising are
wrong cruising along star field and then
there's some faction i pissed off five
galaxies ago just start pulling up on my
ass that's what i want like i want an
in-depth fashion system to go along with
this big world i want the game to do
good got a two dollar super chat from
spartan ghost one one seven uh star
photo didn't look too hot for me either
i agree it's not that i didn't look i
thought the game looked good it's just i
need more information on some of the
the features that they said in the game
like the thousand plan i want to know if
there's some version of a vat system in
this game i want to know i felt like
they didn't really go into too much of
the combat
so
so like you just need to know more
information about the game that's what
you need yeah i felt like they did a
very good job showing
the game i felt like they showed a lot
of aspects that people would it would
ask they went big into the creator uh
the create the creation creator
but i do feel like they could have went
no more and that now obviously they're
not going to do it all we still probably
got maybe even more than a year because
i don't think this game probably ain't
coming out before next june i hope it
does
but if it needs to be pushed back even
more i'm cool with that
but that's just my thing it's like look
another two dollar super traffic spartan
ghost of 117. also can't wait for mods
to fix the game for me that's cool
but i do want to point out that we
shouldn't have to rely on these people
to fix the game
bethesda should have this game
up and running and the mod should add
more value to the game not the other way
around
oh my god i'm starting to lose my voice
man starting to lose my voice
um you can expect your bases being rated
see that's cool that's the kind of stuff
that i want i want in-depth thing on
that i like how you can make ships you
know they should have showed us the the
the mass type of ships that you can make
can you make them huge are they just
going to be one size you know what i'm
saying like i kind of like how the
kingdom hearts games or you can you know
they gave you like
kind of a a diameter of how big they can
be i want more stuff like that that's
all i want
yeah
uh two dollar street chat from g's after
final fantasy vii being skeptical it's
perfectly reasonable
uh final fantasy oh f no fallout 76.
yeah they follow something uh two dollar
superstar from john tj high attic
everyone is my friend turk
is that my friend dirk yesterday what's
up buddy how are you doing man it's on
tv what's up that's all i'm saying man
like
star filled i'm hyped for it i'm excited
for it i just want to see more that's
all and but i will say that
this is the first time we've seen game
play this is the first time we've seen f
anything related to this game
i do feel like it is a good first
impressions it's just we need to see
more on these thousand planets we need
to see how they're going to generate the
planets uh we need to go see like some
of they're going to be purely water
based and you need certain equipment to
get into them
we need to see more and that's all i'm
saying i'm not saying the games will be
bad i love bethesda games that's the
crazy part
bj you know me for years have i not
always spoken highly about bethesda
games yep
and that's the crazy part about this
chat coming at my head you guys are
right there on my phone man you guys
want to slip my jugular that's how much
you guys are but you know it is what so
let last question guys last question
after seeing this
the show
this xbox show with star fill fall
everything included
do you think it pushed the needle for
microsoft do you think it pushed it down
or you think it just kept it exactly
where it is we'll start with dirt um
i think
i think uh it puts the needle slightly
let me explain
i think
um not just our community not just the
hardcore gamers like us
i think there are some people that's
interested in star field more more than
they were before
now there might be some that's less
interesting but i do believe uh
starfield has caught a lot more interest
um you know like some of the game pass
deals you know like riot games and some
other things now
as far as the hardcore gamers maybe not
but i do think overall it puts the
needle slightly not huge slightly i'd
agree with that i do think it pushes
slightly uh
i do feel like with the delays of red
fall and starfoot i expected more
but i think persona showed that they're
doing better in the jrpg lane uh even
though i don't really particularly like
kojima it did show that they're working
with that studio absolutely i i like the
fact that they're bringing some kind of
from software to game pass day and date
didn't that didn't do a whole lot but at
least we're getting the game and only
are we getting the game it's going to be
day and date in the service and stuff
and i know bg ain't a big fan of game
pass uh but i do like that the fact that
they are not only give helping them with
the development i don't know what they
did i don't know if they helped them
make the game poured it or whatever but
i like that they're going above me all
making sure this stuff come up there
persona coming on the platform by itself
is huge i've been wanting that franchise
now hopefully we'll get final fantasy
stuff uh clearly we're getting something
if snitch is right which probably he is
we just gotta see more we gotta see more
of it i think this you know if we were
saying like
like this is the needle like it went up
like this like nothing like this
yesterday it's
slightly slightly
increased i don't think it it did
anything drastic i don't think it
lowered it i i do think they showed you
value in game pass they showed you gains
for everyone here's the thing
microsoft
came past is the center
but they got to appeal to a lot of
people the caterpillar one caterpillar
two candidates three got a pill a lot
now if they continue these these
conferences with that mentality instead
of focusing on a lot of the hardcore
audiences you're gonna see a lot of this
stuff because they're trying to they're
doing a shotgun approach they're trying
to shoot as many people as possible and
not just trying to hone in on one person
uh
obviously when you do this type of stuff
you're gonna have a lot of shows where
people are waiting 35 45 minutes on
multiple [ __ ] that has nothing to do
with them
that's subjective that that should be
changed i don't know but how do you feel
uh bg
did it push the needle did it lower it
or it kept the same to you i think it
kept it kind of the same uh like i said
it's it's been divisive um i've been
listening to all the xbox fans right
and
there is from what i've
seen and heard listening to all the xbox
podcasts
is
um definitely some disappointment there
with a lot of the games that were shown
uh general happiness
about i think a red fall and star field
and a few other games but
from yeah like
i think xbox like this xbox show seemed
to be like a whole bunch of variety
uh
like variety and diversity but it wasn't
like what xbox fans really wanted to see
you know that's that's what i was
hearing that's the i agree
i think the biggest thing that the
majority of people wanted xbox fans and
non-xbox fans is we know that game pass
is going to get a lot of good indie
games a lot of good double a triple a
content into game pass we wanted to see
what are their people doing more i think
that's the biggest thing is what is your
exclusive content and i felt like they
short they fell short a little bit you
gotta fight out superchat from jj needle
goes up tremendously once the
abk deal goes through i think that's the
activision yeah
it's
well you shouldn't say dirt no i'm gonna
say something as a as you know uh a true
xbox fan i will say this
you guys are right okay let me explain
why i was initially
disappointed with part of the show
because even though i like a lot of
indie games
we're we're waiting for we want that yo
we know you know you guys have announced
hellblade you guys are now survived
perfect dark fable we're waiting for
these games
to be shown
in a great light right because we know
these games are in development
but we're just waiting we're like damn
it we've been waiting right so we've
been waiting for the you know like the
second half of the xbox one generation
and so now yes we love the road map the
road map looks incredible for xbox but
now we want to see these games we want
to be blown away visually oh my god look
at the graphics like you know how
hellblade 2 was at the game awards last
year yes that's what we want we want
some of that visual just oh man littlest
dope that looks dope so if we didn't
really get that at this show but looking
back at the show the show wasn't bad so
that's what
some xbox fans
were upset about
um but i think most of us got over it we
we realized their strategy for the next
12 months okay we get it um so so like
what bz said it was it's kind of true
that's that's what i've been getting
from most xbox podcasts some people
um like they love the show they like the
show
uh some people thought the show was
underwhelming um so but some people just
felt that
we didn't see all the big bangers that
we wanted to see yeah and i think that
that's what that's the biggest thing but
i do feel like i don't know how you guys
feel we're going to end it on this this
new 12 month thing where you know
they're doing twitter talk about this um
i'm kind of curious where you guys
thought process on this do you prefer a
show that focuses more on the the the
near future like the 12-month or do you
think that they should show us more of
you know a couple years out uh we'll go
ahead and start with bg how did you feel
about this and do you think that i think
the center of us not seeing some of the
stuff that we thought like about was
because of this this new direction
absolutely absolutely i think i think
you can do a mix right
obviously you can't show
five games that are all coming out in
2024
but i think you could show two
right
you could show two
um and the rest
the rest can be anywhere you know from
this year to to next year
right
um
yeah that's how it should be something
you know long term to look forward to
and something more uh and things that
are more immediate to to late next year
um
and you know even something that you
know might you could even announce
something that
is in development but you know in
pre-production or not really in
development but it's it's been greenlit
you could even you know do that so you
got to be a mix
yeah um
you know i
agree with that let me say this
in 2020
xbox had to announce all these damn
games right because you know
they had no games really announced at
the time and
um
they needed to show a road map so all of
those games had cgi trailers right and
obviously most of those games are like
five four five years out you know which
is unfortunate but you know we look
like we wanted to see a road map because
we just didn't get a road map
um a few years ago so
i do agree that
a couple games will be okay just like
even the kojima thing they announced
that game is probably three four years
away maybe two or three years away right
but i felt like that that is funny that
that was the only game that they broke
that 12-month thing for yeah yeah so it
won't but see they want to let people
know yo kojima is working on it it's a
big announcement just because i
particularly like the individuals games
uh having him on your side is a huge
thing
absolutely i think this is how i would
like it in a perfect world
i don't feel like you can have one or
the other exclusively like you got to
have a middle ground when it comes to
that i feel like
i remember one year they think it was a
long time they showed a bunch of games
and then they got to a part of the show
where someone came and said this is the
stuff we have in the future and they
showed like five or six games at that
point like i feel like that's the best
format i've ever seen them do do the
kind of pacing you have now 360
generations
yeah do do the pacing you have now and
then
20 minutes left of the show
someone comes out set expectations
correctly the beginning someone comes
out and says 12 months and then at a
point in the show
what you have is you have someone that
comes up and they said the future this
is the future of xbox i think that's the
better way now i'm not saying
do what you want to do you're a
multi-trillion dollar company who am i
saying but me is a fan
i do prefer to be teased a little bit on
stuff that is coming into this i agree
with that you know i agree with that
because i don't know what e3 was but
they was up there it was before phil was
the head but
he was the guy that announced that he
said now it was one part of the show you
said now these games is for the future
of xbox i i think they use the word
beyond or something like that uh you
know so yeah i do agree with that but
let me say this now if they use this
same strategy actually next year now
because randall thor was on on like wbg
this past week and he mentioned this and
i wholeheartedly agree with him if they
use the same strategy next year
they will probably have more of those
bigger games than we wanted to see right
well but i do feel like we'll get to a
point where if they keep doing the
12-month thing you'll get yeah yeah they
can't do it every every year will be a
surprise because we're no longer got
spoiled i think that's the biggest
problem dirt we had expectations because
of previous formats that they've done
when you show us fable avow
ever wild perfect perfect
hellblade and then we get to a show here
now where we're like okay you bought
those studios years ago we're expecting
progress now we're expecting showcases
of these games and you don't get them i
think that is kind of like
the it's been a circle and now we're
expecting more of that circle but when
we don't get it people just get
naturally disappointed yeah so see the
thing is though they have so much
develop i mean so much content and
development
i think they're in a good place right
now all right let me tell you something
now you remember when playstation i
think is e3 2016 which is a great e3
sony's 2016 they announced uh spiderman
and the god of war
days gone they announced all of these
great games
so
and even later that year they announced
the last of us too
so what happened
they were like the next two or three e3s
they were showing those games
um because they showed them like maybe a
little bit too early or like well like
one or two of them too early so for the
next three eight threes they showed
those games over and people like yo the
gameplay looks great um so
my point with xbox they have so much
content in development
yes there are some games they can hold
back for a next year's show but at the
same time what you guys are saying is
absolutely right there has to be a
balance
you know i do love the 12-month thing
but i really love what you said addict
the 12-month thing is cool but
then there needs to be a part of the
show where they say yo now these games
these upcoming games are beyond the
12-month window you know it could be two
or three games but that would be a dope
thing to do so because you don't want
them to you know you you open it with
the 12-month
model and you end it with the future
model because i feel like
an unannounced game is going to be a
better mic drop moment than showing
starfield i know
i loved it but i did kind of miss that
drop the mic moment that we couldn't get
because starfield was the ending part of
the show
uh so let me go and get these super
chats we'll go ahead and get us up out
of here we got a ten dollar super after
jiu jitsu 50. it definitely made an
impact 50 plus games coming in game pass
the next 12 months road map is
impressive eighty percent of the
multipliers are coming to game pass i
will admit value of game pass was
definitely double insured sure some of
them didn't apply to me but others did
but i don't think that first off people
need to understand that nothing is made
just for you there's other people that
it counts too
another ten dollars from jiu jitsu fifty
the road map map has over 20 first party
games which is very impressive also
something that sony hasn't showed us
well sony ain't really showed us much of
anything this year uh but i do think
they have games this year i think this
is a solid year for both companies i
just do think in terms of like first
party sony's definitely you know
delivered a little bit more yeah but uh
you know
bg what what where can people find yet
man
world looking like these days
uh it's looking pretty good man um
you know i'm on twitter broken games hdr
you know it's the youtube channel
uh y'all know weapon wheel podcast y'all
could check that out but uh you know
some of y'all don't like me but you know
you could follow me anyway
yeah they was gonna look
i'm always gonna fight that look i get
it people
they don't like bg
i love them not liking me though i feed
off of it
i love that you're feeding his internal
battery man what about you dart what's
what's been going on with you
almost man just uh you know doing a
little podcast on monday nights um 6 30
eastern time wbz xbox podcast
um you know doing my my normal little
content here and there i you know i did
a little live stream yesterday
um so yeah that's about it matt on on
twitter i'm at griggity so just hit me
up that's about it man all right so now
i'm going to go ahead and tell you guys
now next week is going to be a little
bit different we are going to have a
developer on
and
how it's going to go is i'm kind of
going to start having these series now
next week's going to be it's not the
attic show it's the attic spotlight
and pretty much i'm going to be talking
to devs about like
in-depth breakdowns of their games uh so
keep that in mind some of you ain't
gonna apply to come back next week for
the attic show but next week it's gonna
be more of a serious you know side where
you know i'm going to be talking to them
about
what goes in their role keep in mind
we're going to be bringing up their role
you know exactly how it goes from a
day-to-day being that person not going
to go over who it is going to be yet uh
we will talk about that probably i'll
probably announce it on iop this week i
got to get verification that they are
coming uh probably the week after that
we're going to have one two but then
after that we'll be back to normal
because normally after e3
being content creators bg dirt what
happens after e3 well this e3 it's dry
as hell when it comes to snow yeah it's
the worst time yeah uh so i will be
sprinkling makeup on that
so appreciate ever coming through man i
hope you guys enjoy next week um i don't
know who we're having as a guest on iop
this week uh let me bring up let me
bring it up
i don't know if i'm allowed to tell you
so i probably won't tell you
uh okay so we're good we're good uh oh
yeah it's supposed to be ran and jazz
random jazz and kid smooth uh we're
supposed to have them up there i think i
announced that already but i appreciate
everyone coming through man and until
next time this is the gaming attic we're
out here peace
peace out later